So if we're going to be talking about strategies
in this game that has an uncertain ending,
we can't just write down sequences of, of
actions anymore. We can't just say cooperate, defect, defect,
defect, defect. Or even some kind of tree
of possibilities. Because those are going to be finite
representations. We need some other representation that allows
us to play for an unbounded number of rounds.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And I'm going to start off by presenting
an example of such a strategy, one that's,
that's very famous for the iterated prisoner's dilemma,
and it's called tit for tat. And the structure of tit for tat goes like this, on
the first round of the game, A player
playing this strategy will cooperate, and then in
all future rounds, the player is going to
copy the opponents previous move. Does that make sense?
>> It does. So basically, we start, I
start out, acting as if, you're going to cooperate
with me. And the moment you don't cooperate with me, I will start
to defect, and we'll be in the, the old style prisoners' dilemma. Right?
>> Well no, not. What this says is that it actually copies
the opponent's previous move. So if, if an opponent goes cooperate, defect,
cooperate, defect, cooperate, defect, defect, defect,
defect, cooperate, cooperate, cooperate. You're going to
see something very similar coming out of the tit for tat agent.
>> I see, I see, I see.
>> In fact, we can represent the strategy as
a little finite state machine, like this.
>> Yeah, I like that, okay.
>> And you, so you can see exactly how it kind of proceeds. It starts
off cooperating. And then in each, each round it waits to see what the opponent
does. That's the green letters here. And
then it follows the corresponding arrow, to
determine whether it is going to cooperate
or defect in the, in the current round.
>> Sure, that makes sense.
>> So in this picture, the black letters here
represent my move. And the green letters represent my observation
of the opponent's move. Or at least if I'm being tit for tat.